[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara guten abend schön dass sie dabei
sind wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sport ein und das sind unsere themen
heute
boden gutmachen spitzenplatz verteidigen
endspurt im bundestagswahlkampf
forderungen aus kabul die taliban wollen
diplomatische anerkennung von
deutschland und finanzielle hilfen
botschaft der vielfalt aus tokio die
paralympischen sommerspiele enden mit
einem grellbunten plädoyer für ein
harmonisches miteinander
genau drei wochen noch bis zur wahl die
spannung steigt und erste annäherungen
finden statt
spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz würde am
liebsten mit den grünen regieren auch
deren kandidatin baerbock kann sich das
prinzipiell vorstellen nach aktuellem
stand der umfragen bräuchten sie aber
noch fdp oder linke dazu unionskandidat
laschet besuchte heute mit der kanzlerin
in die flutgebiete in nrw nicole
diekmann
gruppenbild mit kanzlerin der dame die
armin laschet kandidatur schub verleihen
soll die hochwassergebiete schwieriges
gelände für den nrw ministerpräsidenten
mit einem lacher in einem unpassenden
moment handelte er sich massive kritik
ein liegt derzeit in den umfragen im
abwärtstrend und auf platz zwei
offiziell sollte der termin ausdrücklich
nicht lasch kampagne dienen
wir haben heute die erste brücke
gesehen die wieder funktionsfähig ist
und das nach wenigen wochen das war
möglich weil wir nordrhein westfalen ein
planungsrecht haben das sehr sehr
unbürokratisch ohne
viele vorschriften ermöglicht hat
einfach zu beginnen wir können jetzt auf
einige dinge die die landesregierung
beschlossen hat nämlich planungs
vereinfachung beschleunigung
zurückgreifen selbst auf der bundesebene
auch davon noch lernen und wir so ein
land führen kann kann auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland als kanzler
führen gleichzeitig in potsdam
wahlkampfauftritte es in den umfragen
führenden spd-kandidaten scholz und dem
schlusslicht annalena baerbock von den
grünen beide haben hier ihren wahlkreis
beide wollen mit einer koalieren aber
beide wollen ins kanzleramt könnte schon
gruppe ist eine regierung gebe wo die
beiden parteien die hier präsentiert
repräsentiert sind dabei sind wenn wir
uns das wünschen können ja eine eine
regierung zwischen den parteien die hier
in schönen gummistiefel farben vertreten
sind aber wenn der echte veränderung
brauchen und wollen dann muss grün ganz
vorne mit dabei sein rot grün grün rot
schwarz grün groko ampel rot-rot-grün
kenia jamaika heute sind viele fragen
offen heute in drei wochen um diese zeit
sind die wahllokale geschlossen
schauen wir auf die korona lage das
robert koch institut meldet zehn 1453
neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden
2037 mehr als vergangenen sonntag 21
todesfälle binnen eines tages kamen
hinzu die sieben tage incidents steigt
auf 83,1
in rom sind die gesundheitsminister der
g20 staaten zusammengekommen um über
weitere schritte in der korona krise zu
beraten
gesundheitsminister spahn kündigte an
dass deutschland bis ende des jahres 100
millionen impfdosen für die
internationale impfkampagne zur
verfügung stellen will ziel sei es noch
in diesem jahr mindestens 40 prozent der
weltbevölkerung zu immunisieren
die bundesregierung will nach wie vor
freies geleit für tausende ortskräfte
und gefährdete personen in afghanistan
im gegenzug fordern die taliban jetzt
von deutschland diplomatische
beziehungen und finanzielle hilfen das
sagte ein taliban sprecher der welt am
sonntag kompakt
männer unter sich rund drei wochen nach
der machtübernahme der taliban hat in
kabul der markt der geldwechsler wieder
gehört nur ein kleiner lichtblick gute
geschäfte sind momentan rang die währung
im sinkflug die preise steigen geld wird
knapper banken wenn sie geöffnet haben
geben nur begrenzte beträge aus es
bleiben zweifel ob die neuen machthaber
irland tatsächlich stabilisieren können
eine wichtige sache ist arbeitsplätze
für die jugend des landes zu schaffen
egal welche regierung da ist aber sie
sollten arbeitsplätze für die jugend
schaffen um sie hier zu halten
doch die taliban benötigen dringend
finanzielle hilfe aus dem ausland
allein aus deutschland sollten dieses
jahr 430 millionen euro fließen die
derzeit eingefroren sind auch starke
diplomatische beziehungen wollen die
taliban aber auch künftig nicht
verzichten die taliban sprecher
mudschahid der welt am sonntag sagte die
deutschen waren in afghanistan immer
willkommen sie haben viel gutes im land
getan schon zu zeiten des schahs leider
haben sie sich dann den amerikanern
angeschlossen aber das ist jetzt
vergeben
gleichzeitig machen andere klar was sie
nicht wollen warum frauen nicht so
mächtig wie männer sein können fragt die
reporterin
weil die sicherheitslage im land ist
nicht zuletzt dass eine frau in hohen
positionen der regierung arbeitet sagt
der kommandeur aber vielleicht können
sie in zukunft in hohen positionen
arbeiten im pandschir tal kämpft die
taliban weiter gegen den widerstand ein
us-general warnt inzwischen vor einem
bürgerkrieg ein machtvakuum könnten
terroristen wie denise stärker machen
nach einem messerangriff gestern in
berlin prüfen die ermittler mögliche
islamistische motive ein 29 jähriger
afghane soll eine landschaftsgärtnerin
mit stichen in den hals schwer verletzt
haben auch einen passanten der ihr zur
hilfe eilen wollte zum motiv hieß es
dass der mutmaßlich psychisch kranke
tatverdächtige sich daran gestört haben
soll dass die 58 jährige als frau
arbeitete
in montenegro ist es zu heftigen
straßenkämpfen gekommen der grund die
weihung des dortigen griechisch
orthodoxen kirchen führers die
versuchten demonstranten mit
straßenblockaden zu verhindern es gab
auseinandersetzungen der polizei ohne
deco hatte sich 2006 für unabhängig von
serbien erklärt in der amtseinführung
sehen die demonstranten eine
machtdemonstration des pro serbischen
lagers
großartige sportliche leistungen bot das
deutsche team bei den paralympics
trotzdem nur platz zwölf im nationen
ranking so weit hinten wie nie doch
jetzt ist es vorbei mit einer
grellbunten feier im olympiastadion
gingen diese spiele in corona zeiten zu
ende mit dem plädoyer für eine welt in
der die menschen mit all ihren
unterschieden harmonisch zusammenleben
können christiane hofmann hat mir
ein junge aus tokio sid die para
athleten überwindet dadurch seine
vorurteile gegenüber menschen mit
behinderungen der paralympische effekt
so die idee der abschlussfeier soll
tokio japan und die ganze welt verändern
bunt und optimistisch enden die
paralympics
ich habe die spiele in vollen zügen
genossen und bin auf jeden fall sehr
dankbar dass wir sie machen konnten
insgesamt aber ein gespaltenes bild die
spiele waren von corona überschattet so
sehr dass regierungschef zurücktrat zu
spät habe die regierung auf die stark
gestiegenen infektionszahlen reagiert
die krankenhäuser am limit
viele menschen haben gefühlt dass die
olympischen spiele eine negative
auswirkung auf die korona situation
haben und wenn es nur deshalb war dass
sich die regierung nicht nur auf deren
bekämpfung konzentriert hat
leuchten in vielfalt der wunsch dass die
paralympics auf die japanische
gesellschaft ausstrahlen in der menschen
mit behinderungen jahrzehntelang
ausgeschlossen waren es war eine große
chance zur veränderung doch es gibt noch
viele barrieren und ich denke sie
betreffen die gesamte gesellschaft
in drei jahren ist paris olympiastadt
die spiele von tokio sind vorbei
[Musik]
ja schon ein bisschen schade oder auf
jeden fall hatte ich gerne gesehen das
ganze aber es geht ja munter weiter mit
sport highlights etwa die springreiter
heim-em in riesenbeck da gibt es gold
für deutschland nach silber in der
mannschaft am freitag siegt andre thieme
heute im einzel und das bei seiner
ersten teilnahme an einer
europameisterschaft
andre thieme wunderbar abgehoben mit
seiner sharia gelandet auf wolke sieben
einem himmelsstürmer gleich das erste em
gold für deutschland seit 14 jahren mit
einmal ist es passiert und so richtig
haben wir gar nicht mitgekriegt
nur einen fehler darf sich thieme im
wimpernschlag finale erlauben und der
kommt früh aber der 46 jahre alte reiter
aus mecklenburg vorpommern behält die
nerven
europameister im springreiten vor dem
schweizer fuchs links und fredriksson
aus schweden das geld coop wird starker
vierter
beim formel 1 comeback der niederlande
ins antwort schafft maxplatz tappen den
heimsieg vor titelverteidiger lewis
hamilton und übernimmt wieder die
führung in der wm gesamtwertung
nach 72 runden beben in zandvoort die
tribünen max deppen gewinn vor 75.000
zuschauern
36 jahre nach dem letzten formel 1
rennen an der nordseeküste sein sieg
scheint nie gefährdet denn schon am
start seit der red-bull-pilot von rechts
sein können fliegt der konkurrenz
förmlich davon auch sein team reagiert
auf die taktischen spielchen vom ärgsten
rivalen mercedes bestmöglich sodass
verstappen ungefährdet zu seinem siebten
saisonsieg fährt auf zwei landet lewis
hamilton verwalte roboters sebastian
vettel wird dreizehnter mic schumacher
letzter
die deutschen volleyballer haben auch
ihr zweites vorrundenspiel bei der em
gewonnen gegen co gastgeber estland
gewann das team souverän mit 13 0 sätzen
olympiasieger alexander sphärisch hat in
new york das achtelfinale der us open
erreicht der 24 jährige hamburger führte
nach sätzen mit 2 1 da musste der us
amerikaner jack sock im vierten satz
verletzungsbedingt aufgeben
es wäre verlängerte seine siegesserie
auf 14 erfolge und hat weiter seinen
ersten grand slam titel im blick die
deutsche nummer eins trifft nun auf den
italiener jannik sehen
das war es um sport dankeschön norbert
fehlt noch der blick aufs wetter viel
sonne lokal aber auch zäher nebel oder
hochnebel am nachmittag im nordwesten
dichte wolken aber weitgehend trocken
höchstwerte 20 bis 28 grad im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn spricht
marietta slomka mit csu chef markus
söder wir danken für ihr interesse
wünschen ihnen alles gute tschüss bis
morgen wenn sie mögen